could you run five miles in 40 minutes
March 12 miles carrying 65 pounds of
gear and go for a swim wearing a uniform
and combat boots all while operating on
one meal a day and minimal sleep that's
just part of what it takes to join the
elite Special Forces known as the US
Army Rangers and this week two women
became the first female soldiers to
complete Ranger School and yet even
though captain Kristin Greist and first
lieutenant Shea haver have completed the
training they won't be allowed to join
the elite unit why because even though
women make up around 15% of the u.s.
military's active forces most frontline
combat jobs are off-limits to them that
includes the Army Rangers in 2013 the
Pentagon ordered all positions to be
eventually opened up to women
the military has until 2016 to justify
which role should be exclusive to men
but that doesn't mean women haven't been
fighting already in modern warfare the
front lines of conflict have become
blurred women in support roles like
truck drivers bomb disposal experts and
military police among others have been
caught up in combat situations alongside
men but as long as combat positions
remain officially closed to women so do
the benefits that includes combat pay
and certain awards the lack of official
combat experience also limits promotion
opportunities for soldiers keeping women
out of the military's highest ranks the
recent Ranger graduates as well as the
Navy's decision to open seal training to
female sailors is a sign that this could
be changing still there's a lot of
opposition to women on the battlefield
but why well some argue they'd weak in
the armed forces women they say will be
physically unable to keep up with men
and that the standards will have to be
lowered to include them others say women
will make things more
located logistically like requiring
separate quarters and unique medical
care another argument is that allowing
women into combat units will affect the
camaraderie among male soldiers some of
whom may be attracted to the women it's
worth noting that the two women
graduating from Ranger School did so by
needing the same physical standards as
their male counterparts as for unit
cohesion that argument has been made
about every change to the u.s. military
from racial integration to the repeal of
don't-ask don't-tell if it opens the
door to women in combat the US military
won't be alone a number of other
countries including Canada Israel Sweden
and Norway already allow women on the
battlefield but what do you think should
female soldiers be allowed to serve in
combat